all right here's here's lamar jackson
from the complex load management podcast
admitting that in the divisional round
against the titans things went wrong for
the ravens because they maybe didn't
take their opponent as seriously as they
should
be taking it one game at that time i'm
not picking ahead
right that's what happened in the
playoffs and we ended up losing
to the 10 people that had us favored
over you know but it's any given sunday
you can't understand no team no opponent
and that's what we did so um i'm looking
for this 2020 season playing the browns
first
yeah hey look that
it's it's it's a hell of a time to learn
the lesson when you go 14-2 in the
regular season and you get to the single
elimination round and you get caught
flat-footed in that first game but
that's one of the things we always talk
about and it used to be about a 50-50
rate that the number one seeds would
lose in that that first home game in the
postseason the divisional round they're
playing a team that just played the
prior weekend you got a titan's team
that knocked off the patriots they get a
lift from that they're feeling good
about themselves they got nothing to
lose the ravens may be tight remember
that remember that question once they
clinch the one seed what do you do with
17 and they they gave lamar jackson and
other key players the week off so you
had a three-week break between actually
these are all things that need to be
filed away and factored in now moving
forward it becomes more important
because only one team per conference has
that so it's gonna be more focus on
those two teams that have that bye week
because of the expansion of the playoff
field but valuable lesson that i think
coaches need to remember as those one
seeds get locked in in late december
this year
don't take your foot off the gas
sometimes it's hard to find the pedal
again
yeah i think that's the real point mike
you're spot on i mean new england's
taught us that right if anybody i mean
there's a team that's been you know king
of football for two decades and they
never rested their players week 17 when
they had a one or two seed already
locked up so yeah you know first off i
appreciate lamar jackson's honesty i
always think that's cool to hear from a
football player you know you could kind
of feel it in that game watching it that
the energy was not quite the same with
the baltimore ravens oh yeah it's
tennessee great oh nine and seven
you know no big deal we're baltimore
we've been stomping everybody you know
it did seem that way to a degree and
then mike i think your point about the
end of the regular season is very real i
mean not only did they you know lock up
you know the first the first seed and
the the home field advantage and all
that but really never had to play a team
that was threatening to them down the
stretch that's right like you look at
their last three games new york jets
cleveland browns pittsburgh steelers you
know when they didn't even play their
starters in that game against pittsburgh
steelers you know they went three four
weeks in a row with not walking on a
football field and not really feeling
threatened or scared or not like can we
beat this team we better play our best
and i think between that and yes like
you're saying taking your foot off the
gas pedal and then them being just a
hair sloppy in that wild card football
game uh it all you know formed a
snowball downhill of course and uh they
ended up getting walloped 2812.
yeah and now the question is that
you've got the the time and it's a
different kind of an offseason and you
can't help but wonder right because one
of the things we always talk about when
you see an offense a player whatever
take the nfl by storm the defensive
coordinators that will be facing that
team the next year go back to the
laboratory and they spend their time
coming up with ways to stop that offense
to stop that i remember the the wildcat
and the the the read option and how
we're going to stop it yeah they devoted
their time and effort to stopping it
this year you know when we hear all the
various coaches say how much more work
they're getting done at home and they
can really focus
now look you have to install your new
defensive approach and there's going to
be a challenge there but if anything the
pandemic has given the defensive coaches
more time to focus on ideas and
brainstorming and scheming ways to stop
the baltimore ravens offense again good
luck teaching it to your players when
you don't have that
i usually would but but you at least you
at least have time to come up with more
ideas
you do you do and i think listen i think
that's a great talking point or you know
subject to to talk about anyways because
you're right the coaches are gonna have
lots of answers but where
where do you draw the line here
especially early in the season hey yeah
hey i'm mr defensive coordinator i got
25 new defenses i'd like to break out
this year but i don't want to overwhelm
my defensive players and then get them
so confused that we mess up our basic
normal defenses and play sloppy that way
to me that's going to be the big issue
you know especially with like an offense
or teams in the afc north who maybe
wanted to dedicate a little time in the
offseason right you got like a week you
know you know your first week of otas
teams might go hey we're going to do a
30 minute defensive walkthrough and
we're going to go through adjustments on
the baltimore ravens and what they do
and we're going to kind of adjust our
attack and game plan and the fact that
you miss those walk throughs and the
players don't get to see it and make
calls and communicate with the other
players that's going to put them behind
the eight ball and and i think you know
baltimore's only improved their
offensive players there and their
personnel to make me think they might
have a few more tricks up their sleeve
this year too and they'll be ready to go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports